你如果能够做到隔离，
做到漠视，
做到不再被他的行为牵动你的情绪，
你就胜利了。
真的跟NPD相处的话，
最终的胜利一定是他的所作所为，
在我看来的话，
不再牵动我的情绪，
这就是我的最大的胜利。
在看了您之前所有的那些视频之后，
我就觉得那些婆婆跟我的婆婆比起来简直是不值一提，
他们都是善良的，
我婆婆是现在70多岁了嘛，
还有两个儿子，
我老公是他们家的老大，
他在我老公很小的时候就懂得那种苦难教育和我觉得是道德上的绑架，
他可以自己吃完东西之后就拿一个月饼跟我老公说，
你看我只有一个月饼了，
你跟你弟弟分嘛，
就会这样。
还有我老公小的时候，
他比如说做的不好，
他就会找我老公的爸爸去告状，
告状之后老公的爸爸就会发脾气揍我老公，
或者是我老公他们弟弟，
他就会做好人安慰呀这样那些，
但其实是他挑的事情，
比小象人家夸张多了，
我看了您这么多直播和视频之后，
我觉得他就是很典型的NPD，
他会幻想自己就是家里面的公主，
我们结婚了之后，
他就会直接说，
我从小都没做过活啊，
我们家里面都是我哥哥姐姐那些，
我爸爸他们对我特别好，
有什么吃的都会给我啊那种，
反正很有优越感，
我那个时候就。
是亲妈，
绝对的亲妈，
她生我老公的时候她是难产，
所以她这件事情她每次都要跟我老公提，
我老公就会觉得她妈妈对她付出特别多，
所以我老公属于那种很愚孝的，
我经历了视频里面的各个阶段，
咱们直播间里面的各个阶段，
我开始也会觉得凭什么会有这样的人，
他不爱我老公，
会去要挟我老公。
我们恋爱确定关系，
恋爱到结婚现在已经16年了，
我们的家庭关系还是挺好的，
因为我是独生子女，
我们也是一起白手起家，
包括我们结婚的时候，
他是外地的，
我们开始说因为家庭经济条件都一般，
也没有想花家里的钱，
所以我没说要结婚，
没说到婚礼，
他妈就觉得很需要把给出去钱收回来了嘛，
之后就提前20天说他要办婚礼，
我们就自己筹备婚礼，
从始至终他们一分钱没给，
也没有彩礼，
甚至是连会庆家的时候都是空手来的，
但是我老公临时去超市买了点茶叶过来，
因为我们家庭条件比他们家要好一些，
所以我们家也没有在乎我爸妈还跟我说，
说别给他太大压力，
也不说要房也不要车那些那确实他最后跟他爸就说要买个房，
在我们在的城市给了个首付，
后来还房贷是我们两个一起还装房子，
买车，
包括筹备结婚都是其实是我爸妈给的钱，
结了婚之后，
我们一共办了二十几。
说我们家的亲戚过去，
亲戚朋友过去，
可能也就3桌，
因为毕竟比较远嘛，
要是过年期间，
后来结婚收的彩礼，
他们全都留下来了，
一分钱没给我们，
就这样，
我当时都还没有觉得什么，
我现在已经过了那个阶段，
觉得不平衡那些过，
但我现在看不爽他，
我就想报复他，
我们到现在为止给我老公打电话，
除了要钱就是要东西，
要么就是索取，
我就会觉得很不爽，
母现在已经不爱我们的孩，
现在已经分开姿了，
是不是分开住了？
我跟我老公大吵了两架，
我就说的很清楚，
以后我不会跟她爸妈住在一起，
你们家孩子多大？
其实这个婆婆参与过带孩子吗？
她是跟我妈一起带的，
但是她单独带住有半年孩子，
对他奶奶感情怎么样啊？
没有感情，
我感觉现在这个状态就已经是很完美的状态了，
你都说了，
他有可能是NPD，
我跟你说跟NPD的人相处只有一个方法是最好的方法，
这里对，
是的，
没错，
就无论你跟NPD的人摆事实讲道理，
说他多么的偏心，
说他对孩子造成了多大的伤害，
他不觉得，
所以他是不会产生愧疚的，
他也不会产生对自己行为的反思的，
没有的，
你现在就已经很好了，
你就已经解脱了，
你就已经远离了，
而且这个事情目前还是要去的嘛，
不是，
而且这个事情哦，
你千万不要扮演那个说在你老公面前。
揭露他妈妈是多么的NPD，
他摸么是多么的残酷，
千万不要扮演这个角色。
有的时候人很奇怪，
他自己心里可以怨恨，
但他不允许别人来提醒他怨恨。
是的，
你现在需要做的就是漠视我。
说句更那个什么一点的话，
当她已经不存在了，
假设你的婆婆真的如你所言是NPD的话，
那我今天就讲点更炸裂的观点好不好？
NPD根本不能算是我们的同类，
你永远不要试图跟跟你不是同类的人去讲道理，
去摆事实，
去讲对错，
就像我们永远没有办法跟狼去讲道理是一样的，
狼如果要撕咬你，
狼如果要吃你的肉，
狼如果要咬断你的颈动脉，
你觉得你跟狼能讲明白道理吗？
你说你凭什么咬我？
你凭什么吃我的肉？
你凭什么喝我的血？
你有没有同情心？
你有没有怜悯心？
你觉得狼会听你讲道理吗？
我讲到这儿啊，
你要问我要不要去报复他，
我告诉你，
最好的报复是漠视他，
当他不存在好吧，
其他还有什么问题呢？
其他的倒也没有了，
因为还是看一视频，
学了很多，
毕竟还是要把自己的家过好，
对你如果能够做到隔离，
做到漠视，
做到不再被他的行为牵动你的情绪，
你就胜利了。
真的跟NPD相处的话，
最终的胜利。
一定是他的所作所为，
在我看来的话不再牵动我的情绪，
这就是我的最大的胜利，
目前还做不到，
因为每次看到就是那种生理性的厌恶，
那你就多了解，
多研究NPD，
多去听那些NPD的受害者，
他们是怎么走出来的，
他们是怎么战胜NPD的，
他们是怎么战胜自己的情绪的开关的。
只是会有一个顾虑，
因为我老公属于那种很孝顺，
即便我什么都不说，
所以我会很担心，
以后你只要管好你的儿子就行。
还有一点，
说这话就釜底抽薪，
如果我老公愿意跟他住的话，
这是我老公的决定，
但是我会带着我的儿子单薄，
好吧，
谢谢，
好，
就这样啊好，
拜拜啊拜拜。
因为很多人可能不太了解NPDNPD它是真的挺常见的，
有数据显示，
我也是查网上的数据啊，
未必是权威的，
6%的NPD当中呢，
男人和女人的占比还不一样，
你们觉得是男的多还是女的多，
你们自己可以去搜这个数据，
大概四个人里头，
四个NPD里头三个是男的，
一个是女的，
大概是这么一个比例，
NPD这个事儿啊，
你想占6%是什么概念，
就100个人处理得有6个NPD，
其实我有的时候我看到这个数据的时候，
你知道我心里揪心的是什么啊，
这背后是有千千万万个孩子面对的父母就是NPD，
因为我们成年了之后，
我们要谈个对象，
NPD,
我可以分手啊，
结个婚，
找个N。
D,
我可以离婚，
但是孩子面对NPD的父母，
那真的太可怜了，
你们如果不知道NPD是啥呢？
咱们就作为一个自我保护也好，
学习也好，
你就去搜什么是NPD，
包括我以前也讲过，
关于NPD的一些特征我都讲过，
而且NPD它往往是打窝，
打窝是什么意思呢？
一家子好几个，
往往是一家子好几个NPD，
记得点赞关注哦。